it's Monday Brennan I want to tell you
all that's true yeah oh oh let's try hey
man we have a new head handshake
everybody let's show them what it is we
go like this already bro so what Shing
so we please sign on yeah yeah you guys
brother well Shing see Shing brother Sui
we pump [ __ ] up our fists and then like
with our thumb to the sky but it's
talking to me to tell Curnutt just tell
them the handshake we do their [ __ ]
where you have yep right Oh like a
pancake make a stack stack our dicks on
top of yours
I have thrice now dick dick dick dick
dick dick dick snake snake talk that's
it and then we walk off the one that's
it I can't believe you remembered it
because we wrote in a stack and stack it
dick dick dick head the head a snake a
snake might take we're gonna put them
together yeah then you bend over and
whoops that's a lot of Lube there on
your cellar burn oh that's okay I'm not
gonna put a summary mix okay that's a
summary talk into the mic it spits out
just yeah anyway we're working on the
song you're dumb so I'm just gonna try
it out we'll figure it out I had an
interesting conversation with my
neighbor who's a plumber
he owns a plumbing company for Italy yep
yeah he owns like it's good to have a
plumber next to you he's he owns upon a
company I bet he's seen some [ __ ] oh
I'll be here all weekend I'll be in
Oklahoma Saturday check him out plumber
seen some [ __ ] when you have a plumber
he has everything what do you need what
do you need you need propane no problem
well you need ladders
what kind of ladders you want a lot of
adjustability right no problem you want
to stop raccoon he's got [ __ ] how
many guns you want a gun from World War
two or you want a new gun whatever you
want that guy's got he married married
by the way by the way to other things
he's got his wife had some fat tittays
his wife is beautiful and she finds
Highland I knew it like every bit hey
ready
[ __ ] no dude dude I don't know where
we're going with all
no I mer has everything no no married
lady no no no boy no he's he's he's
actually awesome
he's got tortoises and he keeps bees
over this giveaway don't worry yep
so I get myself raw honey I got tortoise
eggs not really but if I wanted them I'm
sure I could get some dude why don't you
get it tortoise bunch of baby tortoises
I could my dogs though find them very
interesting yeah yeah but he's got a
horse it's got everything else meanwhile
he's sneaking a drain there's a guy it
does use the snake router uses a he's
got all kinds of snakes
now now though you'll find I was talking
to him and his son you'll find like
underwear you'll find all kinds of weird
[ __ ] right you found weird [ __ ] in there
yep yep so there's a guy he helps he's
got a huge huge house huge house and
when you have a really big house and
you're really rich get in the water from
the tank in the garage stuff all the way
up you got to have a certain like like a
pump and all that help some with that
this guy's muscular thighs his beard
probably 54 years old I don't do Ritchie
[ __ ] yeah but a guy was fighting it you
know he's probably on a little
testosterone and father to hot young
wife he's got it going on man Bella's
got he's got yep thank you he's got he's
got Porsches he collects cars demands
he's rolling you know that salami hug
he's made it
yep drain is he's anal to about his
house and rain is stuffed mmm so we
can't figure it out my my man goes up
gets his old snake that's the old snake
out starts to snake the old drain well
you know what he finds in that drain fat
black dildo no [ __ ] bro but he's found
those I don't know where result of this
what's he fine well yeah like it holds
out a shitload of condoms because the
condoms had blocked the thing he goes
there's your problem and the guy goes I
got a bigger problem than that you think
goes what he goes on them and I use kind
of
my buddy went well I'll just uh well get
rid of condoms I'll you nail the bill
have a good day sir good luck with your
wife yeah with a you latest they sure
were shoes games today there was a whole
bunch that means that means gangbang or
the guy's a belly or gangbang yeah maybe
it was a bel-air game but just 1196
South Benton yeah I do them there no
wait a minute
dude yeah that's how you get caught
that's how you get caught and by the way
it had been going on in his bed for a
long time because there was a whole
gaggle of them I mean a whole gaggle of
it just kind of the work allowed or
something yeah
travels down the road on the road it's
lonely yeah then them trouser snake it
before my age got a lot of young Holden
shiru she's probably in her 20s late
twenties early thirties expects sir
right if this huge crib yeah you got you
guys got trainers come to the house to
work huh oh yeah work that guys like you
why'd you spit when you said that broke
oh gosh thank you because I'm working
visit why gosh you know gosh like you
got me crazy what happens when you're
older like myself is you want to hold on
to your youth and I don't know I don't
know I might embarrass myself Golden
Arrows myself my dog's been sick for
eight days it's nuts til he's five he
was back down he's back he's back they
thought it was poor you think this is
his back is an infection but it gave him
a whole bunch of gabapentin which he was
like what the [ __ ] loopy he's better now
he's when we come over put him down the
cork is back no not really I don't dude
listen I see what you're putting down
here yeah
and I'll do that for you Wow you only do
it after the show no man I do I will do
that how are you how would you put my
dog take his little face that shut us
now I take these two [ __ ] fingers and
go you know what
I hope Peters hearing this and I hope
they blast you with Twitter's all cuz
I'm helping your dog a dog you're a dog
murderer no and you know what you were
smiling when you just said that so
you're kind of man who you were winking
at you get off
killing in your week winking at me I'm
trying to pick up where you pinned down
my oh my core you down for free my fat I
brought him to the fourth fat my VAT was
the first three - no no before that
comes in now I'm not exaggerating she's
a supermodel she smokes shows that
supermodel it's like oh no she's good
looking at her she's a super on I
started laughing as she was talking and
she was looking down I started laughing
you tell you she looked up and I said
I'm so sorry but if you were a vet in a
TV show people but I would say that's
aren't that I said you're a super
monster laughing she's she goes oh my
god you gonna make me blush I go but but
I'm serious like you're what were you a
model she goes no I just and I was like
but yeah it's hilarious it was actually
funny so then I they wanted a bad joke
she starts talking about that know you
or did you did you get your guns I go
Terry snakes are gonna be some of these
pythons or smack you're gonna be
embarrassed you're gonna you're gonna
cringe now do you dig on go oh well do
you anything for this big old no trouser
snake no I didn't do that I was like to
work on snakes exotic animals hain't
good use because here's a spotted owl
did yep yep do you have anything for
psoriasis of the dawn no oops your mouth
I didn't do that that would be in the
porno instead I embarrassed myself
because she was she said we can give
your dog this and that and I said I
don't want to over medicate and I know
you know like for example ready I go I
box oh and you know when I spar my hands
hurt so I got a doctor I didn't go to
the doctor I made the story up I go I
got a doctor and the doctor with box
gets worse I go I go to the doctor and
the doctor must give me six different
medications and like and I'm walking out
with Matt and I don't I just take a week
off from sparring this is what I said
now that's a story that Sam Harris told
on his podcast so I know is a still
story it's not true and I said it and I
lied to her and she looked at me oh you
panicked I panicked and I lied I told
the story about going to doctor about my
hands and how I spar it's so ridiculous
thing else I stole the story from Sam
Harris
you had nothing else to offer that's
right and she looked at me and she
smiled and she went so we'll run
she does so um you know we'll just we'll
see make sure he's hydrated and I'll be
right back I was looser looser gently
from for a look for a 51 year old
[ __ ] loser she old she's she's 28
probably cow byre Corgi
come on man you can't use my quarter
yawn bye oh this thing and you're and
you're in a tank top
yeah we can sorry about my shoulder
shorts I was at the beach lifting
anyways my corgis driving me it's how
you doing how you doing holding the
Corgi and one like this one hand what
can we do with this thing not that not
this this yeah
no I'm holding like this right what can
we do with this thing what's wrong with
him nothing
and your what's wrong with him he's all
swollen I think there's some
inflammation
he is Arthur Isaac everything for
inflammation or ten do you know what
he's all swelled up you know you have
anything get the swelling down
anything yeah I ain't cuz I'm 12
tell you thirteen dude when you're
talking about that plumber story
oh no but I before I moved to LA at this
house in Denver of Greenwood in
Littleton and uh you know when you're
taking a picture I kept your keys your
phone or something my singing pissed and
so I was like you know say my name I
turned and for the reason I dropped my
keys my only keys oh my on my dodge
Dodge Challenger and Hummer went on
there and the house keys there's only
one master house key and then I was
taking a piss and went ha and I just
came both in the perfect time I got a
movie or TV bad sitcom my keys fall as
the toilets going down no you know and
I'm like oh no I don't know do so I call
my brothers like I don't know what the
[ __ ] to do that probably went all the
way down so I call my dad who's like
your Navy has everything - the tortoises
and the ladyboys
but he goes don't harvest the tortoises
he goes my dad's like ooh I guess he
like you might be in luck because
towards the end there's like a net thing
that attached deep stuff if it's a newer
house so it doesn't allow the big things
to go through so you might be alright
we should gotta take it off and maybe
it's it within that net thing in my car
let's do that dad comes over and he's
like is this he's a guy he can't wait he
had like the specter gadget like this
big one needs to go to knees like
dressed pretty nice it's really nice
yeah get those tools he's like I don't
wanna sweat too much so he takes a toy
he's like Oh dad don't shake the toilet
over your face oh I got the keys and he
goes he do he just goes hard turds
myself ah [ __ ] I know my dad do a team
fun here who's not happy oh that's
terrible
good not stop I was in tears I said
close down he is all that I use a whole
roll other people team I would clog the
toilet every three days my father-god
god dammit god dammit you ever had to
get your deuce Bigalow on and [ __ ]
really crank down on that thing
god it's tough I'm really squeamish
about [ __ ] I don't do oh [ __ ] now man I
don't do well like my son I give him a
bath rune iton like few weeks
[ __ ] in the tub I started laughing I
thought was pretty funny let I drain the
water then I get the [ __ ] out and I was
like oh yeah did not do well with my son
still at six just decides I'm not gonna
wipe to that [ __ ] and I'm like bro I'm
like dude you wipe i'm i bend over touch
your toes and it's just like I'm like
getting your ass in the sink right now I
gotta clean his ass don't ya make
anxious ass in the sink yeah that's what
being a father you'll wash a lot of ass
I'll watch some ass yeah
doesn't bother me doesn't bother me I
don't yeah it's tough dude now it's
summer though it's [ __ ] summertime
you know you're on your kid stretch when
you're kid you probably but I don't went
to the well and like I don't know if you
had water balloons but and I was a kid I
used to have to take the balloons go to
the hose somehow MacGyver my [ __ ]
balloon onto the hose turn it on yeah a
day they get big on your fat titty I
take it [ __ ] turn it and then I was
like you laugh of my friends like you
can't even throw is so big what is a
beast you know they have now my son
loves water balloons they have now this
thing where it's a little connector
right to it and then got them 20 [ __ ]
balloons are there and then when they
fill up like grapes on a vine
pop pop off yeah I'm like you little
[ __ ] you have no idea you throw you have
no idea how blessed you are when you
throw those hard they don't break
sometimes we'll just hit a kid in the I
know they'll go break usually you know
there's different kind see you Brian the
quality [ __ ] I get my ship from China
China that [ __ ] pops like a cherry yeah
we throw those at each other stop there
there dude they fill up their dough yeah
they're so cool these little bastards
have no idea look three packs of a
hundred so you put one on you have a
hundred water balloons crazy you have a
[ __ ] hot 100 they come out like
cherries it's true there's so many
things now you have no idea and then
you're super soakers yeah that's a good
time we'll spend all day on the Sun with
kids and spin all down in a pool crime
hammer that remember that until your can
you come out looking like you're 90 cuz
you're a prune because you're so
Napoleon skin I know there's really no I
used to like hang ice to hang our place
in they were shared in Colorado called
celebrities was like a big pool air you
drop kids off his doll
there's Southshore there's not a lot of
those anymore huh not really I had a
party I had a pool party at my house
this weekend all the kids I made a
mistake of smoking weed do you kids I
don't you know I'm not a weed smoker so
I decided okay went on people I smoked I
took a big hit and I'm not and whenever
the last week was yeah a guy and
whatever the [ __ ] it was I I was so high
that I couldn't and people were guests
we're trying to talk to me oh I couldn't
don't make eye contact little worse
brother I was like oh yeah and I would
run away I don't do it in person
oh never I'm not good with that happen
ever I just because I can't drink so I
said I love that idea who I know some
people can function Rogen can operate
heavy machinery he can do a dude I'm a
crossword puzzle [ __ ] rewrite the
[ __ ] amendment so not really well
well let's be honest you know what I
disagree didn't do stand-up I shot I
guess with Germany where he Waldo stares
at the mic know when you when he like
shakes death stars and he was like on
another planet he was out of his body
experience yeah but like he shot it he
shot his first rush on that flicks the
first take sober and they're like all
right second one high and they're like
homerun
Wow some people are like that yeah
that's what I hear he's mr. amazing set
one Simon Rogan's where we were at the
ice house we were doing this podcast and
in the back room and I and I drank some
whiskey and I smoked some weed really
and I wrote [ __ ] on stage I got up and I
wrote I did this amazing journey I stand
up on the spot I think it's so much fun
it's my favorite show to do it I'll do
it should do is August 30th while I'm
remembering I'm doing a fundraiser for
my buddy who is a dwarf and has medical
issues and had a major operation so
we're gonna raise some money for him
well at the Comedy Store main room
August 30th me you I'm gonna get broken
again everybody I can't August 30th just
see you guys [ __ ] you Larry fun is what
night is that that is I don't know I
think it's Wednesday Tuesday Thursday
something like that
hey by the way you've done tan tickets
are up right half price yeah that's
actually funny
I'm gonna make fun of him there's a
really funny comic oh he's a comic oh
yeah it's not Brad
no no it's another small Dave ollie my
buddy Ivan man his emails no neck Dave
because he has no neck nice yeah well
I'll definitely be at the hot so August
30th and then that's Thursday the
perfect day and then um come see me this
weekend just I want to say this right
now just so we can sell as many tickets
as we can
Tampa Tampa Friday Saturday tap improv
love Tim do it well we have some fun
love toddler they'll have some fun yeah
well I got myself an air B&B
well did you hotel there's my hotels
they're a nice habit Ybor stating that
Stan stop good food yeah who are you
going out there with alone really doing
it alone solo damn I wish I could go up
if I know
Oklahoma on Saturday I'd go with you
really yeah great not only charge you
have lineage what I got you a nice hotel
in Chicago
that's gonna be fun I'm excited for
should go yeah yeah I I'm staying there
too the Thompson well I hope we're
staying together don't tell him where
we're staying edit that out I don't want
the fans really I'm just kidding
obviously yeah
was he in tell you was it Oh Thursday
night I tried doing the hat trick I went
I went improv you know what to drive
this is I went improv 8:30 comic store
at 10:00 and I was gonna try doing
Rogen's show at the ice house 11:00
that's ton of all around so tough I know
I couldn't make it
it's good I am Sam put me up like in the
middle sighs I've done at the comic
store like 11 you discover good [ __ ]
when you do three sets in the night [ __ ]
yeah I find you so which I did that's
great
what do you do dude how about um I'll
[ __ ] I'm gonna forget his name and
drives me fun crazy I posted about him
on his rap on my Instagram story no
I'll forget he's [ __ ] hilarious the
nurse introduced you you know forever
just [ __ ] me Sam Tripoli no
it's been a staple of County store Rick
Ingram no he was on The Hangover Ken
Jeong nope not Asian what about that one
got seconds Brody Stephens Brody Steve
I've ever seen Brody rotor sin bucking
among goes after me and just just a
crowd work and it was I mean Brody's I
mean I was eight one eight till I die
he's dude I didn't know what he was
gonna I'm an attractive man I've never
seen it and then he goes out there and I
was like what is he doing I guess he was
a big-time pitcher and since he tried to
Sam was I do she was like no what do you
think you ever seen bring us watch man
yeah I'm like dude what's he doing yeah
it was so [ __ ] maniac he's hilarious
he goes where you from before he gets
goes doesn't matter and then one guy
goes where it from he goes they have it
you just go there it is yeah there it is
yeah there it is yeah Brody's Brody's
he's too proud of it and he goes I'm
here till 2:00 in the morning till 2:00
in the morning
here's I go from here I go work the 2:00
in the morning his Zach outfit aqus fell
in love with Tim went on to earn a
scholarship at Division one Arizona
State here's one state baseball's like
playing at Ohio State football yeah he's
a big deal he's graduate with a 2.5 GPA
yeah but he was a hell of a pitcher yeah
he must been really [ __ ] good
mm-hmm he said that coughing I thought
he's dude I was dying all areas that
kalfa doctors were saying he goes he
goes Brody I hung out with him like
there's the third time I hung out with
him and I get this text I get this I get
this message on my phone and I guess
Zach Brody good to hang I feel like we
can take our friendship to another level
now and just hung up kept playing it
he's so fun oh my god he's hilarious
hope he was dead serious I feel like we
can take our friendship to another level
bye buddy he's great man he's great he's
just a great guy look at he looks funny
he's a maniac
he's a mania yeah he's [ __ ] only one
pitcher the most Ben hasn't really I get
really really good yeah I was telling
Jay Jay and I were trying so hard enjoy
it buddy Jay and I were trying so hard
to get these Yeezys because those are
actually
we went online I thought about getting
you parents gonna I got a plug well I
figured be funny if you mean Jane every
want the whole team had him on I want to
European gentleman like I saw European
soccer coach I might sir just now oh
yeah
someone like time to pass yeah but you
would have made fun of how hard it was
for us to try and get these really the
only good it was holy why are you just
like we woke up early we had us it's
like seven other friends on the site the
site crashed we're talking [ __ ] to each
other because you had to get you had to
be in zone people are vying for it to
try and get them and then I posted like
oh took the Elvis more than someone
reached out that's how I got him Jesus
but uh yeah it's hilarious what are they
how much are they they prove they're not
giving them away well I'm still a tree
tail standard you know very tell ya now
easy boost how he'll Instagram is
fighter it called bottled butter I guess
they look like they look like they glow
in the dark they say we're in the era of
ugly shoe they called the ugly shoe yeah
it is they're really terrible well we'll
look back in ten years ago they're super
you can leave people were though we've
always done that right like you look
back in 90s fashion 80s fashion lights
doodle redoing and then it comes back
around you look at the that's what I'm
fine fascinating about fashion I find
that fascinating because why why why
this now why that now and why why
platform shoes in the 70s we would what
is it like what's going on like it's
fascinating cuz there's a there's a
there's a zeitgeist you know the
zeitgeist said this idea that there's
this there are these movements that we
all collectively kind of walled someone
creates that movement then his flowers
and then they have such an influence on
hip hop or the young generation and that
leaks over to so why do they hen there
becomes a demand then the demand is
limited so that becomes all have these
so you get status yeah and then people
acquire that status why are they
influencers and what what is it about
this declaration I know like Kanye
fascinate white guys it's Ryan Gosling
there's like there's certain things it's
really interesting there's a there's a
like did when I watch the old Steve
McQueen movies pull him up for sex like
I I go that's the style that I should
actually be you know involved in and
that's
because that's as far as I'll go but
then there's some people that just are
more daring and they'll do [ __ ] that you
know he was just Steve McQueen handsome
style though yeah he did but it was
really facing like it was like I'm just
gonna wear that you know you have a
certain body time for certain things
like I can't really wear now your self
floral button-up shirts like the summer
shirts right I look like a giant tourist
yeah so I just can't do it but then you
look at like GZ wearing like god dammit
looks cool you gotta wear for your style
yeah it's very tough I feel like it's
tough to figure out your style
but I got these for Jace Jace birthday
Saturday and they get them these should
be pretty stoked that's great you guys
in your shoes you know three two kids
ridiculous but you were like one pair
you know you'll just when you walk when
you wake up in the morning you go poof
what do I got to do now what do you mean
well I mean I only have an hour and I
have somebody to choose to choose from
what am I gonna do I wear the ones with
the buckle I wear the one with the
flashlight built into the sole I know I
mean I know it's tough but we so yeah
figure we have some time to figure out
your outfit for Chicago I know I'm I
gotta just go we'll do it on Monday me
next week yeah so I got a Ralph Lauren
come on you just want a black shirt and
jeans right and then with adidas we get
this all done off Abbot really yeah for
sure okay if adidas there I need a soda
it's a full black boost oh you want oh
yeah yeah they ever I do yeah I think
that would be good for sure agree you
know or maybe the black Golden Goose
like this do that to work yeah that'd be
cool too for sure and it supports my
incredible have you ever heard of big
dick style no this new trend big dick
the big dick trend dick style trend what
is that type type that energy cue just
did a whole post about it a big dick but
big dick big dick style that fashion
well yeah you'll see you bring do that
Google that what you come up with long
dick no no no no no long dick stop nope
there it is a guide to big dick energy
stop big dick energy to energy style
it's guys with big dicks in the way they
dress
if they have a something about and it's
a little peacock yeah that guy it's got
a piece on because he's all lanky let's
be davidson monster comic [ __ ] down
in Iran Grande Oh fat dick in a comic
Pete Davidson I don't know he's at the
comic store sign our life tonight live
on fire oh he's hilarious he was opened
up for Dave Chappelle Reese oh nice
hilarious he's like a savant he started
doing Stan Lee's like 16 deadline sorry
Peter I should know yeah oh by not it
started by ariana grande so yeah so the
big dick Energy style entered the
culture by way of now deleted ariana
grande tweet that made reference to Pete
Davidson's Subway jingle Slade sighs
dick so now it's a stop it's like a big
dick energy style god bless and there's
certain like ways that guys it's fat
dicks try got [ __ ] so there you go yeah
I would never well yeah keep going
though dad shoes right now I can't get
into him although the Kanye dad shoes
just released now look at this well
that's a terrible dick though man dude
we're that pretty special call American
boner well dude that's a terrible dick
and terrible leg these legs
goddamn you can't do that well is this
thing like broad it's all red and it's
is and it's got it's often irritated
what did you do that over the weekend
did you drag it on cement and he has a
butt like a red bush what is he doing
just roll a little dick let me see his
face at least pull it down he is right
here so that's a farce got a nice he's
got a nice face but there's a nice jaw
you have a very thin yeah dude and he's
won but if I had that little dick I
would be raw mean either me what I can I
mean I say this with the hundreds and
comments with bigger dick than that for
Sal the courage it takes for him to walk
down a runway with that miniature dick
in his fat bought here's their balls on
awesome it's fat all looking at you
you're you know your bill fat's a big
dick energy son but now he doesn't have
the big dick energy but he embraces the
reason men cover it up when it's not
angry because it's just not inspiring
looking they're not cute no
they're not cute looks just like a bunch
of meat yeah it's like somebody took a
hamburger and mashed it into his lap
it's very strange
oh god dude hey stop dropping it in fire
ant hills what are you doing
so my my son I was taking a shower my
son goes mama dad has a tail I'm like
that's right boy it's a sale
big old tail right big old tip keep
saying that you keep telling your
friends of tail God and so fun antler
till I was I was taking a shower my
little son he was like 3 or whatever and
he just reached up and I was just like I
was washing to grab that [ __ ] thing
yeah I think this is just as funny about
the dick though I know big dick in a
jacket like hey dude do you have crabs
take yeah look at that that's pretty
good
sure dude I meant you're the first
person I was gonna text when I found out
about this LeBron James came to LA the
Lakers how excited are you
you're the first person oh man I've been
a huge Laker and LeBron fan from day one
and basketball fan from day one yeah so
I'm so pumped finally the Lakers are
gonna have their say dude finally we're
gonna win a chickadee did I tried it
I've been waiting so long you guys been
waiting since Kobe and Shaq did I try
buying a official jury this morning yeah
they're sold out you did I'm gonna wait
my turn
yeah how about did I post that how happy
it was I'm a LeBron fan yeah I like
LeBron always like Laband huge LeBron
fan and I post saying Chris D'Elia
starts talking she goes oh wow
never heard you once talk about the
Lakers all of a sudden your fan now
let's get the [ __ ] out of here I'd like
to do this because I don't know anything
about basketball but I like to just go I
like just when I have a bunch of
basketball fans around I'll do this I go
are you choosing to you choosing
LeBron or Kobe first like in your
all-time team or and then we're Jordans
probably number one and I'll just say
that what happens is you know
automatically there's a cyclops
everybody gets quiet cuz nobody wants
get in the argument this would be quiet
in the guy who bag me it's a short
little song yeah Wow
yeah I mean you want a team I mean Kobe
doesn't make his team better unless you
run and then I make his team better
unless you do it around Jay Jay LeBron
and the hoes eh LeBron I said god I hope
it comes to the Lakers and this chance
is gonna go to the Nuggets old-school
guys like who are my age they won't give
LeBron they won't you if you're a super
Jordan fan yeah he's living in the past
too so you know it's it's tough it's all
silly to debate um I think it's [ __ ]
sweet though I'm super crunk about it
yeah I can't wait they do such a [ __ ]
hater so I get my jersey man gonna have
to wait my friend's son his father is a
professional athlete and she's white and
he's black and the kids ten and when you
see that child at ten you go oh well
already a ten you're like you did you
look so you look so different rather
quite frankly quite beautiful compared
to these other kids that are growing
here you're already proportioned and you
look like you're ready to [ __ ] run
for touchdown smooth Wow LeBron is is he
40 or 43 all right it's always has that
it's always that resting stories like
see you always have that resting those
older beasts those like every Greg Oden
Google Greg no man she'll my man
children man child played Ohio State
Ohio State now now he's 18 there oh my
is that hey is that Greg Oden or is that
Morgan Freeman my like what do you got
like he's not playing anymore
he died of old age but he is very young
he's 20 they're no young that's high
school come on click on that it is high
school that's high school get the
[ __ ] try plan against that [ __ ]
guy in high school that's that's he's in
high school 18 there Brian no I swear no
sure he's 18 dude he looks dogged you
know kids
he looks only a couple years older than
me the headline Greg goon still trying
to figure out my life I try and figure
out how old you are why what's quasi not
doing well there's no he's not doing
well he was a big bust and then just he
doesn't know if he's 70 or if he's 23
well you're the one who was telling
about Kwame Brown Oh
was this Jordan I'm and Jordan broke him
yeah draft them and despot [ __ ] do not
stop dude did you see that thing i
retweeted qin about that shark [ __ ]
up that lady so any current events no I
do have as a kind of that but I see the
tweet Wow
it's it this lady's like FINA I put
sharks doing shark things yeah she's
like [ __ ] the shark and the shark
goes what a sure
shark drags woman into crocodile
infested waters in Australia city hold
up [ __ ] cute why the [ __ ] why the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] around with sharks and
crocodiles festive wat like all things
bad mmm oh they remove the video I'm
sure it's on my [ __ ] Twitter go to my
Twitter Jeff Jesus but of course why do
people [ __ ] with animals man I don't
know I have respect for the animal
although when I was around that
crocodile man I slapped the [ __ ] out
when it goes Rico yeah crocodile was a
dinosaur I see these videos of guys in
the water with crocodiles oh that's
[ __ ] hilarious it is
look like were you away your [ __ ] with
that shark also was she trying to do
it's trying to bite it's a nurse shark -
yeah it bitter [ __ ] Nurse Joy she's
hand feeding don't do that
did it bite her hand off no if they said
it chopped up her finger a little bit I
just gave her the fraction a torn
ligament
it's a nurse yeah but also don't do that
why the [ __ ] you want a hand feed a
nerve we were in Tahiti they were
letting us ride the lemon sharks oh no
and I was like that's disrespectful the
shark and then the conservationists like
that's [ __ ] that they're letting you
do that don't do that I was like you're
right right lemon well they're riding
great whites have you seen that footage
no oh really a [ __ ] out of here oh
really oh yeah I thought about the movie
deep blues water rat poor guys yeah Alan
grabbed on the dorsal fin a 20-footer
snorkeling watch please hmm there you go
oh these are like no guys this is true
this is real I promise I thought you
meant like on top like yeah the waves
like no that's a 20-footer
[Music]
wow it's really not that big is it well
it's it's been that's a kind of a small
one big enough to kill you for sure I
wonder why they're [ __ ] what they
like well they say like we Asli paint
the picture them being these horrible
monster still that she's silly once
you're down that's pretty common I guess
sir
and I would never like what do you I
know you're writing a great white see
this is the problem with these super
earthy [ __ ] try to shave their
armpits and doesn't use [ __ ] I brush
your teeth with coal you know I'm saying
like she's one of those people the thing
is you're like I'm one with nature let
me ride this great white great white
goes well there's it there's the two
scuba divers and the shark turned and
grabbed him and the great white and
killed her and killed him
no there were two scientists yes there
and the shark swam around just like that
and then just turn and grabbed him and
pulled him away underwater and ending
and the other scientist never show the
other science the even plane told me
that sort others like this yeah cuz
David David did this David plannin
special like he he ate a banana while
all these sharks was surrounding him and
he didn't have a mask on shadows no no
it was real black newsreel yeah black
man and he said that these two Sciences
were down there and that shark just this
huge great whites as when I turned him
and got him but yeah but but also
various look at j-3 my brother jaded by
the way underwater Jade that it looks
identical he can always breath for seven
minutes eight minutes look at him and
this is real yep he kept his heart rate
down and everything else yeah how long
is he under there seven minutes David
can call his breath forever just seven
minutes yeah that crazy and what
happened he just there yeah I said what
did it look like he was it was just
shadows dude I can only see shadows I
couldn't see watch he opens he takes a
banana and he looks identical to Jay
Chou no look he's gonna eat how can't
eat underwater it's just Justin get a
mouthful of he's just wall it was just
wild and now watch this this is great
they took him a day they it's all
faqatilu pay island where all the great
whites are and he just went down there
how in the [ __ ] this all I have two
hundred forty thousand feet look at this
[ __ ] what is he he's on this really cool
machine
how can you see under one eye like that
he can't it's funny
can't you took the regulator out this is
my thing they'll be like listen I know
he's your friend though but what are you
doing there
like well day old I know I'm being get
your [ __ ] cards out and hide the card
you do magic what like this isn't nobody
he's fascinated with that insurance
things now I know I'm gonna see smoking
I need to see you in Vegas on the
[ __ ] strip doing magic it was just a
way to end it
I'm gonna do this my special this way
I'm doing my special underwater that is
Jay Saab whose ran out of magic ideas
yeah that's exactly what he's doing you
know it'd be funny you should do this
thing you're special but just do with
giant goldfish the ones with the stupid
bags under that here are friends that
just dreamed really too big like their
dreams my buddy Jeff Beecher goes you
know what I want to do I want to produce
the first special from space I want you
to be in a space capsule and I want you
to do your stand-up and I was like okay
well you go ahead and work on that I'll
be over here doing my stand-up here on
earth when you have it all set up you
can shoot me up into space and we'll do
a special there with all the cameras
dude that see I want you in the water
with those things you know and with a
pan I pop their [ __ ] cheeks for no
reason dude can look let's do that but
you we copy David Blaine good idea right
you show them this rice one there's once
with spots all over there these inner
lives yes
look you a bunch of thryce goldfish
special you take that David Blaine eat
your heart out I tell you the story
about the ants about how you can take a
bunch of harvester ants and this guy I'm
Howard bloom who did Rogen's podcast my
other podcast he fascinating guy and he
said we're talking about how the youth
of today like what the favorite thing
for people my age and maybe even now
your age is to make fun of the
Millennials or younger people like they
don't do they just don't do what we used
to do they don't did they don't know
what that hard work is we like to
criticize them every different
generation
we're wrong we don't know that it's a
waste of time yeah but I don't have time
that that young generation actually is
doing things that we find uncomfortable
whether it's fashion whether it's
pushing the norms or yeah or they're
just bucking tradition and we're like I
am an careful
but harvester ants animals does it so
you take harvester ants and if you were
to drop harvester ants into an area they
don't know
the younger ones are sent out and they
go out and they kind of like they'll go
in half an inch out they'll go a half an
inch out of the circle they're cute and
then they come back and they come back
into the inner circle where the elders
are and the elders will like like
essentially pet them and calm them down
and then those who pick up any kind of
debris on a half inch out they'll spit
it out and the rest of the ants will
like you know tasteless what's up then
they get they get confidence again they
get sent back out and they go out
another half inch and the young so the
young ones are sent out to just keep
exploring until they expand and they
find a food source and a place to live
well the old ones - yeah and and rats
rats will do the same [ __ ] better since
they'll send their young out to teach
you that documentary no also rats the
older ones unlike a new one - coming
back do we have all this food and the
older one go cool eat it let me know you
feel and there so they eat it like you
feel good I kept dad he's like nope not
eating that so now what they're drunk
because rats are so smart they're doing
time-release poison so when they eat
them if they go back and they die the
head rad like don't eat that don't
[ __ ] touch that so they have to do
time really it's [ __ ] and they're
even adapting to the time release then I
cow was that cheese off Fifth Street it
was good
give them seven days see how it goes
then we'll go check you know it really
makes you it does make you tomorrow eyes
at people I'm a fan of around like the
Buddhists always talk about sentient
beings like you kill nothing that can
feel suffering when you see with the
more you learn about something the more
dude I feel have a tough time killed
killing things well my friend -
slaughtered a cow and the [ __ ] the
ball
rat the cue ball was in the brother the
corral next to it and the pool was going
crazy now I guess he was trying to
pretend he was going [ __ ] crazy no I
[ __ ] uh
barbecuing the other day some nice
steaks and I finally got my groove back
well you can't say no to steak why you
always grill right I like refer to
myself as the grill master
and now I lost my swagger a little bit I
came to Cali but now the grill masters
back and I I'm grilling and a [ __ ]
[ __ ] not a as you say a black one
hashtag no racist but a black or not day
all black oily a black panther or not a
who was loop the [ __ ] up for whatever
reason there I'm self down his [ __ ]
Lube nut nope it was a yes that's him
the great black wasp came out if that's
a great black wasp [ __ ] whatever the
depth of hell you they live I blame it
on my steak and I looked at I thought
that thing looks like a goddamn a Apache
helicopter yeah nothing is cool look
that's right that's a huge stinger
that's right my son's gonna come out
here and probably want to check out
what's going on that's right I have to
kill you
you kill me and so but I did a big
ceremony I apologize to him I told him
what was gonna happen and I did it very
fast yeah and I smashed him on top of my
flaming young yeah Mitch killed him on
my fleming young and then I went inside
don't save me yawns Flay not jung-mi
because why no real ing mean yo mean yo
se mignon thank you so I smashed I
smashed this great black wast I said no
races yeah I smash this black panther
[ __ ] devil yeah on top of my Fleming
yo the rich and I use that as seasoning
you kept it on there that's actually
took it off and washed it but I did
smash him on the steak that's good
because and now I thought where there's
one there's more yeah I'm in Utah
my sons playing outside of my parents
house and what do I see but a female
white girl a female that I'm sure the
hawk
no you did it I swear on my life I did
he like are you one up in me right now
I swear I have like Panther what was
that that I'm sure the hawk now did I
kill it no I took my son gently and I
brought him back and you know why he
didn't kill I think she has a fight on
your hand
finally all that she does see with the
tree with the gradual hoppers you can't
just step on bro no no no see the orange
wings now they'll come back you know
what look this is you step on a trans
lock good good good any hump stings me
until I die dude yeah that's that see
well that thing I'm gonna eat right I
have a spatula here if I hit that thing
he's at least and get some brain trauma
I don't know if I'm gonna kill him
though when there's a fat juicy black
well I thought you liked whoa or not
there's they eat that on choice oh
they're so [ __ ] big that I I hate to
be a [ __ ]
bone those things around Sydney Crawford
and her prime could be their [ __ ]
making good to be there and there are
black [ __ ] Panther wasps comes out I
go it's almost like if there are
crocodiles all over the water and
there's a bunch of trash on your boat
you jump into water hundred percent
don't [ __ ] clear out a pool Channel I
don't like the attitude right now bro
you're not scared of wasp
I'm definitely scared of wasps you were
nodding like you were like yeah you're
like not a big deal like oh I eat those
people a lot of trash Aloha croc crawl
all over them
some people like Cody Stevens say his
name coyote Stevens coyote he'll that he
lets me confused with Brody things even
I almost want to get stung by ranch logs
just so I can see what the pan to do
with let us set it up dude
let's fight on your special you want
views or not bro we kick it off with
ladies and down Brian count yeah then
you hit the crowd that's good and then
you got people I do did you see that so
much chronic get stung my trance Ock and
then do an hour set he was swelling I
couldn't do it on my finger look at the
size that [ __ ] dude look at the
size of that [ __ ] bro seriously
that's a dead tarantula hawk that thing
is huge
do you what the [ __ ] would we it's got
feathers I don't want to [ __ ] around
that ones I haven't been stung in a grip
by Obie knock on wood that's not guys
well my neighbor keeps bees come over
just step on one that guy's weird um
when's last time you got stung Chan I've
been stung in a grip I feel like my I
know where they're at like at all times
like if I'm outside
you wanna do another they're not
aggressive it's the Japanese yellow wasp
but you have to be very careful watch
out for those black faces Rosen and your
face will melt ah damn and they're
[ __ ] vicious sound like North African
killer bees oh yeah Killer Bee son they
were supposed to they were out here like
a mother in Texas you say but they
didn't really make it I didn't I got
eaten that [ __ ] they just couldn't do it
you know what is coming up that I have
proof now in Arizona you will see
Jaguars you know that right Arizona
Jaguars that yes there there there are
you we're in Phoenix in October you me
feel yeah Ari
big Jay works in one show we are one
show a big soggy [ __ ] Phoenix we should
call it the tarantula hawk tour that's a
good idea
but on to what we should call it the
white Hawk tour it is rare Jaguar
spotted in mountains of Arizona
not worried about it Jaguars though will
kill you that's a 300-pound cat and he's
not hearing it did you know what
Panthers just a YAG wire with a
different skin pigmentation I try with
black you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's right you
[ __ ] it's not a puma it's a Jaguar
yo Gloria chug wah oh yeah chug worse
the males are [ __ ] can get it do you
think about a 300 pound cat good luck
that's it if that was saying I'll deal
with a I'd rather deal with a hundred
and ten pound Rottweiler than an angry
13 pound cat there's so I think that's
what the hot bet then no oh yeah what
the hot ones say though she said you
have amazing eyes but if she said that
whoa whoa girl don't worry about any of
that if I'm there I will jump in from
that [ __ ] yank wire or that stupid
[ __ ] cat for he said I boxed so
that's why I gotta get medication with
my hands but I don't take it I just take
a day off from sparring not a cat person
bro life I'm not a [ __ ] cat person
no they're [ __ ] killers though
they're killers there's so much does
anyone have a pet [ __ ] transyl huh
I don't think so dude we should get one
for the for the I don't think you I
think they're like great whites I don't
think you can keep them in captivity oh
really
yeah they died cooler there - they're
too fierce and we get one tax can we can
we can we buy a stuffed one
can you google stuff huh we can get on
no way I bet your neighbor has one
probably think you'd do it you date are
indigenous to this area really to to the
enter our Utah to the west do I don't a
catch well in Mexico that Iran plus
stuffed one the whole attraction it's
always gonna be the trash so I'm sure
get that piece of [ __ ] out of my face
wears like a real one bro hey if you're
listening and you know where we can get
a stuff actual tarantula hawk holla
the finally catch up at gmail.com look
at the size of those [ __ ] man that's
how big the 100 how much is that well
that's what sea wasp know same thing
peps this wasp and transmog pepsi wasp
the Japanese no--perhaps Pepsi
Clearwater this pep says whatever cherry
Pepsi while smooth look at that giant
Arizona trash lock so that some of them
are not someone that's a collectible I
need it frame bro I can't have it out in
the open like us [ __ ] psycho prime it
for you
well there was one up top there chin
let's get one for that how much is that
$59
we'll take there's one left bro where's
that drawn no that's a national action
yep it's going into the cart like right
right there
are you ready for fourth of July and
more importantly are you ready for the
fights this weekend I'm ready for any
nobody don't send me happy fourth of
July [ __ ] texts no yeah yeah this is
how I judge if we're friends or not
happy 4th of July
nope happy Father's Day nope I don't
think that birthday make sure you said
you hurt my feelings
Christmas Thanksgiving Easter zombie
Jesus day do not text me birthday I need
extra level
don't forget I'm gonna judge you for the
rest of you I need your prediction on
I'm car wait what are you doing for the
4th though can I put my snake key do
pranks having a thing at his house we
should come
via fireworks yes and you should come
because you should bring tea great what
time and your girl I'll tell you you'd
be good to copy about their address I'd
like you to come I need you there uh
we're gonna do a podcast though yeah the
morning we're gonna podcast then we
should go right over so I better I got a
pool tiger I'll love it
ah let me check my plans okay I'll go
yeah for real
come come by okay it'll be bad if you
don't all right yeah I just good for
your career
I can have I can make three phone calls
and have everything [ __ ] up hey man
I'm telling you what I can do
hurts a little birdie told me audition
went over well really I should know this
week really or next week what they say
said it was really good
no you decide if they want that or but
listen dude you did your job
I know they made the effort to even say
that I know right
I feel like you good job you don't say
anything I thought you were gonna be
proud I thought you were great we buy me
transyl hawk now you're a good actor no
[Music]
Daniel
well what about watching this fight in
Oklahoma yeah with people go to my
comedy show you buy a ticket Lee Thomas
show yep and then you get to stay and
watch the fights with me whatever my gun
okay go you gonna count you're gonna
call it what are you gonna say you're
gonna talk if you ask me questions I'll
talk into the mic um should be
interested I'm asking you right now
don't say anything I'm you got to put
listen you got to put a hundred thousand
dollars down on this fight way either
pick the winner you so much Rachel
hooked you got a pic no it's gonna cost
you a hundred thousand dollars if you're
wrong
oh yeah my gun you're head of your real
money yes who do you got DC really my
decision well you know what I like about
that what and I'm tell you why I'm going
with DC did you think I was it's a steep
a I did you didn't I did and the reason
I'm going with and ste pays the majority
goes a steep a yeah and I understand
that they do but I got I got this to say
about Daniel Daniels wrestling is as
good or better well and I'm am saying
better of course it way bad of course is
and done the same and I saw one chenkin
ste pays armor that was this car
that's fight well the only caveat with
that is did you ever see steep a against
JDS his card is pretty few against
telling him in that you're right he lost
by it split destroyed his card as granny
[ __ ] Stella yeah but there's also no
grappling in that really right the other
thing is DC's cardio then breaks the
ground there are very similar fighters
but I think you know they're both close
quarter fighters they fight in a phone
booth everyone say Oh ste pays the big
guys reach DC's always dealt with reach
and height he's always been at
disadvantage it's not a problem for him
I think DC beats everyone on that UFC
roster not named John general credible
that's how good he is I think he wins by
decision the only way steeper is gonna
win this I if this goes past the round
it's that's DC all day the only way
steep a wins this is if he connects with
that power in the first X right but DC
to me though the other reason we've
already hit right DC I mean you've
sparred with these I don't as far both
of them you spar both of my training ste
pay for a year-and-a-half in DC but the
thing is with DC I don't think DC is the
most athletically gifted man in the UFC
I think he is athletic ops Eve's an
Olympian but I think his mentality is
better than anyone yeah and I also think
his fight IQ is better than anyone yeah
he's incredible so he knows I the one
thing impressive fighter but the one
thing was steamy do you look at this
physique I think however I agree it's
physique like what the [ __ ] he's very
smart he's awfully articulate when it
comes to commentating but the other
thing is is when you look at what's T
pay does well what DC does well
DC does everything see beta is better -
the power punching the KO punch yeah
that isn't liability that he pays a very
good boxer
but I say Stevie is a better boxer than
then Daniel I think Steve pays may be
the best boxer in the division I mean
you know but remember DC to avoid that
big punch you know he beat you at the
Johnson twice I know yeah that's very
true yeah and then also there's also he
outs struck John Jones in rounds he's
beat John Jones in rounds
yeah the the big caveat the big caveat
with DC is he's susceptible to head
cakes that's right
EPA doesn't kick no you said you said
that he you when you sparred Daniel he
just keeps coming he just keeps coming
he just keeps coming he's a bull the
worst the absolute worst I was exhausted
that pressure pressures I can't give
anything off your timings all [ __ ] up
they close that distance he jump up on
you yet doesn't matter and then you're
getting taken out same pressure for five
rounds his cardio is remarkable but that
that comes from being olympian from
being a wrestler and also trained with
Cain Velasquez all your life
Steve alaska's that's true but he has
more knockout power and most what are
you Cain would be a better wrestler if
he wins this it's I mean it would be
such a what a what a way to retire good
he won't retire we'll fight John Jones
at heavyweight Brock Daniel true fighter
great fight um next fight is obviously
tea city and Holloway
I'm never betting against max Holloway
nor should you
yeah I have obviously T city's about us
but any b-cup Swanson got to give it up
you knocked out Frankie Frank and
knocked out frankly this is incredible
so he's on a roll undefeated
yeah but Holloway always goes long he's
probably got better hands he's better
striking he's not as as well as a
finisher though no but he'll probably be
able to stay out of danger when they
coach that's what most think yeah I
refused to bet against Brendan we all
know that max Holloway doesn't get tired
nice Holloway's seems to be doing the
same [ __ ] the same pace on round 5 as he
is round one I love notes
yeah well he's Hawaiian but what's his
nationality what woods he he's a mix of
something some Asian yeah Filipino
probably I'm gonna say Filipino Jaws
it's a Filipino oh yeah fill it cuz
there's a lot of Filipino influence and
in Japanese and Filipino influence in
Hawaii
Simonne right Samoan but something else
to write not just America
beautiful native hawaiians simone and
ancestry yeah there you go
it makes sense he's a [ __ ] monster
511 - so tall first he's huge 445 but
shows t city he says no both as a boy T
city and him are both huge they'll both
go up to 55 their futures at 55 okay
you'll see them fight at 45 right twice
then you see them fight at 55 once or
twice they're great for each other there
are two peas in a pod
they're me find each other for next two
years it's gonna be perfect
yeah it's exactly what we want hey I
liked your interview with with Dante
while there do you do really great I
thought it was I thought it was
outstanding and I think that I think
that I've never actually seen see the
thing about you is that I think you have
two things going one you keep it funny
two fighters love you yeah and the
reason they love you is cuz you've been
there yeah three I'm not jealous either
like you know you're not afraid to ask
the real questions and three this may
not mean this this is I really think
this plays a factor you're really a big
strong guy you're you're you you meet
these guys halfway so when they're
talking to you I don't give a [ __ ] of it
smug Dante Wyler I don't care who it is
they know in a room in a room if it came
down to it you're right there with him
do you understand what I'm saying I'm
not saying you can box down say well if
it's a fight you know we know it's
because on that plays a factor in
respect that plays a factor I don't like
their talking to a colleague yeah
they're talking to a guy who's been
there no guy really understands the
emotion of what it's like to fight on a
big stage to deal with negativity to
deal with positivity and to deal with
victory and defeat so yeah so I got that
from him like he just feel safe those
guys feel safe with you man yeah so the
interview when I'm listening to the
goddamn interview with the one thing
that I really got out of it and the one
thing that I really believed after that
interview was that and I of course I
have a lot of respect for Anthony Joshua
but I do kind of believe that Anthony
Joshua doesn't want to fight Dante
Wilder right now yeah the same thing
really
yeah just Parker's you know phenomenon
yeah they're all these guys talked and
so you guys you understand all them talk
on
pax chat and let all the talk to each
other fury Parker Joshua and wild are
all talk to you I'll talk the other all
like you know boys they're on the same
business yeah so they all get it so yeah
it's just the the you the one thing that
consensus is that Joshua's team not
Joshua Joshua would fight him right now
Joshua's team doesn't think he's ready
right now for rather right but they're
go he's the draw will fight anyone
yeah but the boxers I've talked to who
are real boxers who'd gone through all
of them have while they're winning
because they think that dot that that
Joshua is a very conservative fighter
he's a traditional question and of
course Dante is not not that way he's
wild um you have the other thing too
with the athletes come in a lot of them
when they come in we you know we're
talking before and after I fear a lot of
them one you know everyone's looking for
the next thing
mother there no middle of the career end
of the career begin the career all of
them want to parlay into something so
most um asked me advice about that I bet
so there's like I bet so we have like
I'll try no you're older than these guys
now and you pincer yeah let's do it
and yeah man I mean and they want to
know how you've converted yeah you know
yeah so yeah maybe that's it's really
interesting but you could you can feel
it like you can feel he's he's like with
he's like it's like Dante's there with
somebody he really trusts yeah he knows
I'm not gonna like again I'm not a drum
breaking story like got you know like
patients have a conversation you're
having a conversation with all the
podcasts we've ever done helps yes
because again I'm not there's no
breaking news if he came in with hey
dude I want to talk about my daughter an
issue she's having school for next time
I'm like let's talk about your daughter
in her school issues for like that well
that was no agenda that was what I
notice too what you were listening to
him yeah and so with a journalist it's
it's they have questions they have to
get out they have to get to the producer
whatever you were just going like this
you were going huh huh discovering [ __ ]
was happening yeah and that's kind of
what the difference between having
podcast you know and and they even
edited it every was a longer interview
but you know I can't put the poll [ __ ]
thing how did it how was it received how
did it was there any backlash from any
Burns was there any uh yeah and you know
obviously the majority of UK's can be
upset which I listen we break off into
teams for whatever reason they think I'm
all pro wild or an anti Josh I love
Joshua how long have I been praising
John of course how long I've been a fan
of Joshua forever probably long as a fan
of Wilder I've always thought just being
honest with what you love Joshua so I'm
I'm not on I'm no team here I just want
to see the fight right my mom's English
so and I root for England in the [ __ ]
world yeah I went tingle I did I love
England and their English my grandma are
you [ __ ] kidding me so and there's no
for me there's no teams I just
if Josh wants it down I'd do the exact
same thing yeah I'm whatever he wants to
do well you guys said he won't break off
in the team's
you said if he may give you asked first
England yeah they may ask them you
[ __ ] Americans alright alright well
that's what happened I'm in the bomb on
team boxing I want this to happen for
Bach yeah now for England not for the US
for boxing yeah so people you know the
other paintings a bunch but the ratings
are killing it it's all I care about
that's right should be some current
events Gentiles certain events let's go
P go for a piss hard out in the first
one is a article you sent me it's called
reefer madness and meet the cranium
warriors who say this plant will end the
opioid epidemic which I agree of course
you did you and Daddy take it every day
it's like some smoking cigarette smell
not that bad use it every day hey you do
coffee every day so you're an addict
coffees all night if you're not having
the fight I would say it's not it's not
yeah so I actually do less than I did
when I first started yeah keep that in
consideration um I'll tell you this I've
taken a lot of things man
and kratom might help some people
I got vertigo from it I had withdrawals
from it I'm there's something to it man
yeah and it's people who have
pained opiate addictions and pain pill
addiction stuff like that and you take
this to feel better there's something
going on there but you should probably
rather take this then take the other
stuff yeah I'm sure it helps with that
all right
it all has its it's a fact though it's a
narcotic just because you need a left
hook to the face the jab ain't helping
it is an opioid though right I mean
that's what we know period yeah
cravings a billion-dollar business with
thousands of vendors showing it on
estimated 3 million to 5 million people
the problem is it's just it has been
studied enough so like there's people
that sell it and it's it's not like pure
or mixed up so that's how people get
sick but if you have like a good source
I'm listen I'm not opposed to create a
minute that I see all the emails and the
DM that how it's helped people a lot
that's great that's great if it works
for you great
I do think you have to be careful about
cuz as many emails that we've got that
it's helped people
we've got just as many out there so
drill over in secret talks now it says I
suspect on the plant kratom is not the
answer the opioid crisis but the start
of a new one that's the government
saying that though yeah so the but it
might be based on some evidence well so
it says your chemistry kratom latches on
to some of the same brand receptors that
heroin morphine and fentanyl do from the
government's perspective that makes
creative an opioid like any other and
too dangerous to leave unregulated
claiming that kratom is benign because
it's just a plant is short-sighted and
dangerous should which is true I see a
Scott goggly have said in the statement
heroines a plant the age does coke the
agency are derived from the agency has
circulated notices about known kratom
strains contaminated with salmonella
that's a 44 people anyway the FDA the
FDA goes we're firing warning shots
right you're going to see us crack down
and create them and and I get the whole
well they're not making money off of it
this is a government thing the FDA they
have agendas I get all that with that
being said you gotta you can't just go
it's a plant man they're just dinner
started making money up sort of hating
on it okay maybe a little bit but there
is some truth to
they're saying in some sorts it radom
just not all good chin no we don't know
enough about it what happened we didn't
know cigarettes cause cancer either no
no I'm saying all the research that you
do if you do it yourself you can you you
can judge for yourself what's best for
you right no you do thats not the way
drugs work Shin know right now you think
you're fine you use it every single day
let's just take you for example
okay use it every single day so it took
a day a half off when you said and you
have no idea right so then say a year
from now before the reason has taken
more three years from now he's taking a
little more then five years from our
plan comes out goes listen craters with
link to [ __ ] crazy addiction and
cancer you have no idea I have no idea
people who did a documentary seemed a
little bit confused about it because he
was he doesn't like he doesn't know he
knows he did say that that certain
alcohols do mimic heroin or opioids like
I mean yeah so and we know that from
Thailand it's caused a major you know a
major prize that went into their opium
but that's not that's that's nothing to
say so when people say well the FDA's
and codes with big pharma because they
want to protect big farmers profits on
methadone and stuff like that I
understand why people would say that but
the FDA is not full of really devious
scientists they don't make money a lot
of those guys I'm not saying that that
it's not totally and maybe there isn't
some corruption but the FDA also there
are a lot of good people and they have
to here who are like I think this might
be addictive let's slow down so here's
the other thing that again if it works
you I just keep doing it but we just you
got to be a little cautious of because
they say beyond a few medical case
reports and animal studies on kratom
dependence there isn't much science to
support the idea that kratom is safe or
that it's not dangerous no one yet knows
if kratom works long term and not so
whether you like it like trees family
have just swap one o.p addiction for
another
yeah that's what it seems a lot of
people are doing like mark bell complete
addict Chris Chris Chris Powell his
brother dad Chris addict you know and so
he takes ten a day yeah so you're
the same thing when people are addicted
something then often their ultra
marathon runners okay we're taking that
whatever addiction for drugs turn into
something positive but you're still
getting owed orphans release from
running the same way or endorphins
released from smoking [ __ ] cracked so
you just take it off
Jason Alice former drug addict doing all
that stuff you take those endorphins
they did from that now he's fighting
guys in cages he's [ __ ] jumping
skateboards and jumping big trucks
whatever the [ __ ] he's doing you're just
you're replacing stuff I do understand
that there is people the the optimistic
idea that maybe this is something that's
not addiction forming and gets you off
opiates that you can manage maybe you
know it doesn't seem like you're a
strung-out junkie and you do it every
day so you're a pretty good poster boy I
do but that means I do do it every day
but you do such a low dosage they're
saying they're like it's the same thing
I think with like weed right like I know
people can smoke a little weed and
they're very coherent they get [ __ ] done
that makes it more creative makes it
more functional in society takes the
edge off Rogan says it takes the
complete edge off him he's a nicer
person
he's more loving when he's high for chin
for you this small dose it's just maybe
it's the same thing for a cup of coffe
for me but you don't go crazy and also
by the way everybody has different
chemistry so so that's Ephrata might be
different for you than it is for
somebody else richer for yourself do all
the work yourself and if all the
research I did I weighed the pros and
cons to me it's natural it's a plant
it's not even like add there's no
additives it's just ground up I worry
about like this sort of main I think
drugs personally should be illegal for
other reasons because I think people
should be allowed to make their own
choices but hey you'll a body but
they're chilling means like weed worries
me with kids because a lot of 14 year
old starts smoking weed and it just I'm
sorry but when you're 14 if it's inside
it's not good for Glinda's you're the
development of your brain yeah and they
end up doing I have three friends whose
boys got into the regulates they got
into it no they got into weed at 14 15
16 stop doing sports
stop doing everything and now they just
hang out and it just keeps you
I I'm sorry I'm for me if you're if you
have my chemistry and you do we I can't
get anything done I'm just I'm just a I
just want to eat and hang out so you
know I'm not it works for some people
not kids not kids I don't thought when
did you guys start drinking at what age
I was never 16 I didn't drink it I was
21 I need to hurt alert I didn't tell
anything tells 21 yeah I'm always like
super careful about things I've always
been yeah I'm pretty curious
I've never overdone anything you know
with you know toffee but work drugs
kratom is clearly a drug now how how
strong is it we don't know we don't know
so there was that one study where it
says 44 people died with creativeness
system but then it was just kind of a
blanket statement because they had other
things you say right if you're doing
kratom you're probably not just doing
crazy yeah there's other selfish [ __ ]
like you probably doing cracked gym turn
crack but the FDA I agree they do some
shady business at the same time they
there's a reason we have FDA but big
pharma owns them but that would be great
if they got involved just to make sure
that it was you know the right kind of
kratom like everything everyone follows
the rules of how it's made
then they regulate it that way I think
that would be cool to like you know get
a prescription for kratom it's way
better than if you're getting a
prescription for oxycontin or vicodin or
whatever else they're gonna put they're
gonna make the FDA all bad everybody
there is corrupt there's a middle
there's a middle ground yeah sure lefty
AFC has an agenda but also to just say
creams just a plant man all right no
that's what I'm saying like you just do
the research yourself and if you want to
risk taking it if it benefits you and
you're not having any issues with it
then do your own thing who knows what if
what if we do something else that or
we're doing every single day now and
then later on we find out it's terrible
for you like the way we're sitting down
or my mother [ __ ] well I have to sit
down I'll have to take creative no I
mean the way you sit down like things
like that you know whatever tells you
gets you up in the morning keep taking
kratom sure there's a bunch excuses
right like what if we're in sunglasses
cause cancer I'm gonna wear those am i
right well I guess bro no you're you're
blown out of proportion I think I do
however because
because you guys have talked about this
a lot and because so many emails are you
know text messages or DMS whatever about
this how people are suffering and
whatever when they got off of it I will
I think it's important that I do go off
of it like a couple of weeks instead of
a day and a half well that's the other
thing we've gotten
I personally seen a lot of emails and
dm's about kratom then they weren't
positive people who did it and I've
gotten more and more negative than
positive but not not even come yet a lot
of people like oh I've one guy that you
know was I dude you between that stuff
influences craniums helped me I'm like
will help you great man before the
majority people it's not and me
advocating this I can't just say oh
everything's great you see both sides
yeah yeah it's still a drug yeah there's
a reason all you like it so much
I mean what's wrong with that though if
you feel better from it why is that bad
I'm just uh I don't know and what cost
is really always it's not like an
advocate it all I'm saying is I'm gonna
give you both sides you can't say kratom
kratom crayon and then people like dude
I'm really addicted I got off it it
[ __ ] my entire life up I'm telling you
keep saying take this stuff man you
never said like it I don't say take it
he said I want I did I loved it I also
loved opiates so there's something more
what happened used together you said
yeah withdrawal what happened to you not
the one you're taking and you had
vertigo but the withdrawal part when you
stopped taking out what happened
I just want it how long did that last
take those right now I didn't get
[ __ ] fur to go vertigo was like God
know once you get some yeah I'm out I've
heard you said it felt great and I heard
Rogan said it felt like I was on a drug
when I take it it barely not taking
enough bro take those pills quit being a
baby spoon well order you know or just
stop taking it pop four of those pills
let me know how you feel in the morning
I will be honest I did take those how
many of three or four pills yeah three
four pills one time I felt to me to me
it felt like I felt different than what
I'm taking what strong cuz you're not
taking enough what would those do if I
took no for is good if I [ __ ] for what
would those do for me I mean you just
you just
like getting like the Zen state we like
focus Chatty Cathy I feel like yeah yeah
some people take and feel like they can
like see things the better like you know
predict things and maybe I'll take some
notes
no one should ever did you guys give me
a drug problem talk to your I take those
for real change it Jesus
I don't know oh you ready go this way
yeah but did you see the UFC posted on
their Instagram super thirsty for likes
I mean good they go think about it King
James syncamatic it makes no sense I
mean I get what they're doing I was
trying to jump into the party but so get
me thirsty another one do you guys know
who Lee Daniels is B Daniels is the
director so he directed the butler hey
bro what do you say are the Palmer who
said he died oh the butler yeah I've
never heard of it it was a huge movie
really obsessive you know in the black
community though huh no I think it was
overall success really yeah great
reviews all Brad it's about you full of
the show no I heard of him and they're
gonna have it win up an Oscar oh my god
somebody wanted me I think you won yeah
yeah I don't want to be Tia what that's
right no no I think it won I don't think
so man yeah it was one and double ACP
order [ __ ] guess what you're talking
about yeah
anyhow you can he's a successful
director now I what other movies let's
see what do you say though the butler
and what else I look back her here The
Paperboy odd that was not as you know
I'm a precious oh yes I'm not you don't
I know I [ __ ] know proud gay I think
I'm pretty sure precious one precious
and that move was Sandra Bullock with
the big kid who played football are they
the same person is the blindsiding
precious the same person I'm not
answering that question but don't worry
about the a bread though so what is he
saying right now pressure one Academy
Award that's precious okay anyway so do
you know who Damon Dash's yes so he's
the the co-founder of Rockefeller
Records and when he was with jay-z at
that time that's when jay-z blew up
industry it's a weird Kern event bro
well here it is so Lee Lee Daniels I
guess he when he wanted to become a
director no one would give him money
studios wouldn't give money or anything
but Damon Dash gave him two million
dollars because he believed in him damn
right cool
so Hawk I love that after he beat he
blew up afterwards right so then he
never paid
Damon a day in - back even though he's a
successful director now and he kept he
kept like waiting pushing it off and
going through law going through the
courts so Damon - good - ooh yeah oh he
sued him yeah he's super he's soon after
like 5 million now but he actually
walked up to him at a Diana Ross concert
and then told him he needs to pay him as
two million dollars assignment about
like the money it's about like I did
this for you who would play that how
awkward is look at his face you can't
hear anything
well you could they're going off of the
lip-reading stuff he's like saying as a
man as a black man you know you should
you should have paid me back or whatever
so anyways after all this to Daniel's he
said you only two million dollars he was
no I'll call us no no I need to know
yeah keep playing it there's gonna be
some missing
take it down but here's what I broke my
ankle that's why I couldn't move around
guys
[Applause]
there's none to say
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is so interesting to me tear this
is amazing Damon doesn't [ __ ] around
[Applause]
[Music]
where the [ __ ] are there Church
Hollywood Bowl
I believe it's Hollywood ball and Diana
Ross is on stage diner us is actually
singing right now
[Music]
like hey is anyone can do this later I
swap my money that is kind of [ __ ] up
you got the money those right he has to
be worth my folks peace 20 or some 30
million how you walk around without
paying that money back that's not cool
I'm just leaving you it's the one that
gave you you yeah that's gross to me
it's terrible did you tell he knows he
[ __ ] he had nothing else I'm ashamed
you were wrong make it right didn't wink
you my [ __ ] make it right okay so he
did you out saying I did wrong him and
I'm gonna give him his money yeah just
all you survived into dude I'm a
[ __ ] and I did wrong that that's the
best thing to do good it was so awkward
man I couldn't I can't live with my if I
hope it somebody if I didn't do right
whatever
don't get in my face it's great don't
get in my face
um how about that how funny is that dude
man if I was like as a white man you owe
me as a white man you owe me money man
[Laughter]
about to go public right now you owe me
money I invest in our t-shirt business
ah that's my agent I'd be so convenient
what as a white man I'm owed my money no
I'm like wait right right wait what's
white have to do this hey men like to
white I'm worried doing the Italian
Irish worried man yes with some North
African and Turkish in there cuz I did
my genome and that's not the [ __ ]
point we're in the hood so forgive me
white man you get what he's saying
though I think it's a no hard is making
this business you had no one supporting
you I get two million yeah and we're
both black yeah well [ __ ] I do so from
black denim you know the struggle is and
by the way how awesome is that guy
forgiving him two million dollars two
million dollars cuz I believed him told
you gotta give it up to that guy and by
the way he's a man and he gets up there
any [ __ ] confronts him to go public he
went he confronted him perp man
yeah but still I I that's a man that's a
[ __ ] super [ __ ] about it that he's
off oh well he was wearing a shawl he
was like yeah he had the green ball he
was like this he's all I'm doing a new
Billie Holiday movie goes [ __ ] yo movie
give me my money
you see had all these projects you
invite me to precious that's great
what's wrong with it that means he's a
bad but I agree that means Lee Daniels a
bad person he said you never had to
struggle like for me I'd be like dude
put that guy I'd I'd have him I don't
even know what I'd do I'd have a poster
of him in my house you got to give it up
he Daniels he had all the praise on
Damon Dash but says Monique needs to I
guess he's shut up let's see he's
beefing with Monique God the smell
because you can't he first of all take
the choral all shawl off your shoulders
she's accusing him of blackballing her
in the industry which does happen right
yeah what why would he blackballed her
no no no wow it's so uncomfortable man I
could not live with myself
put put that on there 16 minutes there's
gonna be crowd to find I'm with the let
hey you know what that makes me feel
real good right now my temperatures just
went up like a hundred levels you know
I'm saying you four weeks six weeks
yeah yes oh good tiding it was very God
you there's something about my dish now
all I had to see was that when you get
to mind Oz and you go thanks for the
memories and go off that's not what
that's anyways just this whole his whole
on manners weird vibe you know Maya
precious - yeah I'll take this all back
yeah let me the stud like white
quarterback do it right though right I
don't have don't have unfinished
business I always call it closing the
circles like I don't all my
relationships man I got to close that
circle I got to make it right I don't
want you are the same way I hate
unfinished nasty business especially if
I've been wrong I don't give a [ __ ] what
it is I've just apologized close the
circle don't keep those circles open man
clothes lesser house man if I have a
real problem I got to talk it out and if
I owe somebody some [ __ ] I got a [ __ ] oh
she didn't think him on awards night she
believes he she was blackballed by
afterwards that he didn't pay back two
million dollars so yeah obviously
there's some [ __ ] that's a little bit
yeah I don't know it listen if that says
a lot about you with a guy who gave you
your start and you say [ __ ] that guy and
you carry on with your successes like
hold up dude
remember when you weren't [ __ ] yeah and
no one supported by the way you know
it's crazy we saw the whole story didn't
we we saw the whole story you you can
see oh dude I know the truth now I just
saw it you know I mean that video showed
it all that you you can see the awesome
little cool video game or like a [ __ ]
with that shawl around going listen I'm
doing a Billie Holiday you'll [ __ ] your
Billy all day give me my [ __ ] two
million dollars that's a lot of an
interest as interested in mash goes you
know the capital on that [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] it's true I'll take the capital
that's real money but yeah give him
three million hell yeah Wow remember
when I can afford shirts and then you
put when we were when we were yes do
find the kids shirts I don't have any
extra money I was fighting and you bet I
think two grand friend I took that yeah
but still I was like dude I wanna do
shirts and they gave me that I had no
idea how much shirts rights time this is
whatever six years ago and there was
that that half off advocate or buy a
bikini off when we're at circle in
Venice they have my boy Nick who runs
the app over there think it's still
there and I was a Kalin do you find the
kids shirts I figure first shirt was
like our logo I think and I did that we
can t fight ones I told Brian I'm like
dude it's to grant a time to meet two
again I was making chump change at the
UFC like I can't afford it man and then
Brian was like go here and gave me a
check for to grant nice I went about the
shirts and then we sold out where is my
the bottom yeah they took that where the
[ __ ] is my money as a white man I gave
you [ __ ] $2,000
it was really actually fifteen hundred
but give me my [ __ ] two grand cuz you
know what the capital is on fifteen
hundred dollars as
man Italian Irish guy to a German
English will [ __ ] your native a
miniature 511 168 hey um as the white
man hey man what about our I need your
help with American boner shirts and one
love shirts I know we're doing them we
are yeah okay want to sell them at the I
told you yeah we will I told you you put
the order I'd be really cool so what
about American but what do we know what
wait what about American boner what's it
how's that gonna look we got to figure
that out
whoa we're doing though though the one
love we're not doing American Moana we
can we'll talk about yeah it'd be fun
bring both of them yeah I'd be really
cool as a white man and a white man next
current event all right this one this is
beautiful story Lionel Messi and a
reporter that gave him out his so as the
reporters mom made this little bracelet
that's supposed to be good luck
yeah and the reporter says my mom loves
you you know can you please wear this
little bracelet thing right so this is
this is like a before game we're after a
game where he tied his team tied the
other team so they didn't win the other
team didn't win so the next game came on
and then they won he scored like the the
winning goal right and then the reporter
came up to him after that game and asked
him about that thing so I'll show you
this area masa will get me her mom loves
you more that's me
well I'm oh [ __ ] I carry her red ribbon
for good luck so it's right there again
with that Tamiya move out after they win
so he worked he said did you make the
goal that foot is no the other ones
Laurent
look at it poppies god I love Messi
how about him and Ronaldo out now yeah
and they might only like superstar line
I thought there are they thought I
didn't know Portugal on Argentina had
another game I thought they were out
there out there out what what is that
why when they tie
don't they have a shoot off like a rigid
Denmark day I do oh they did yeah so who
won um yesterday was both shootouts okay
Spain lost in a shootout which was
[ __ ] tragic yeah and then Portugal
lost to Uruguay not from a shootout and
then Belgium ended up being Japan 3:2
[ __ ] thank God now you got Belgium
Brazil Uruguay France so I think you're
gonna get I bet I think we have Belgium
vs. Uruguay and then yeah Frances top of
your grave was really good but damn
France
Uruguay's [ __ ] good man Brazil but I
it's time for Brazil to win mm-hmm
Neymar was like is the is the World Cup
so so now we're in there are there four
teams left quarterfinals yeah now
there's eight teams left does England
plays right and Croatia and Russia play
there you go crucial Russia then you
have two winner of Colombia England
Sweden Switzerland
hopefully it's England there's Croatia
in the final today was just Mexico right
and no man Japan and Cruz tomorrow
tomorrow's England Colombia and Sweden
Switzerland to decide the day all over
those well you're not I record all of
them and chance what the problem is I
only record
my wife doesn't record I keep missing
the shootouts double overtime like what
two shows double overtime last game this
might be a hard thing professor sports
and being a goalie oh my god
I don't think so I think it's the most
difficult thing profession no way you
could make an argument you can make an
argument
damn Japan they were [ __ ] doing the
damn you can also make the argument that
in some ways the coal is the best
athlete on the field all those guys are
amazing athletes so it's a stupid thing
but those guys like Neymar and but
goalies that their their reaction time
their ability did love it too is get
like there you gotta read the body
language maker and then a lot can be
guessing too but those guys are [ __ ]
monsters monster meet a monster I love
the World Cup man I toured it [ __ ]
England Jersey weeks ago um yeah what
else you got - this is the one that's
the best current event you must have
heard about this by now French gangster
who escaped prison twice time about
eyebrows eyebrows John about brows look
he's a gangster gangster red dwarf did
you hear how he escaped me no dude it's
amazing in a bad way but amazing lands
in the middle of the [ __ ] prison
three arms a gunman and one actually
kidnapped the chopper pilot from some
like what badasses man kidnapped then he
held him there inside that little open
area in the courtyard in the jail and
then two guys came in with a grinder
grinded open the door and then I guess
this guy and his brother were like the
brother was visiting that day so they
just grabbed him from there got him in
the chopper they took off and wait they
don't know he's that no no there's a
huge manhunt yeah he got cut he did this
over years ago got caught six weeks
later
okay so what's crazy about this guy is
he so he is to steal your girl in that
picture what it was he owned up [ __ ]
business yeah he's a kingpin right
criminal kingpin he's armed robber he's
really good like getting like dis aging
these robbers he looks like mega mind
but so as a kid I can suck your dick as
a kid his favorite movie was like
Scarface and heat so he was inspired by
these movies oh wow and then it has to
be what did you he got he like broke out
once because he had people sneaking
explosives in a tissue box so he put it
next to the door blew out getaway car
Traver though this this yeah this new
[ __ ] job got everything set up
they found the helicopter blown up yeah
no no he landed and set on fire that's
what they said in the report but I saw
them nothing that was a fire but wait
one more thing so T doing though so when
he was a kid he did all this bad stuff
yet and was in jail a few times and then
he wrote a book after the last time he
got out of jail
wrote a book and went on a media tour
cuz the book was about how you know he
was born and then became just his
criminal that crazy criminal I guess
Scarface so he was kind of like this
celebrity kind of guy and then he staged
another robbery where a police woman was
actually killed so that's when he had to
go back to jail and this is how he's
getting out from that he's obviously
he's out he's probably from Algeria or
he's from Morocco his dad is Algerian
two gunmen in uh baklava LaCava
used smoke bombs and angle grinders he'd
break into the visitors room where fade
was talking to his brother what a cool
story a third man in the prison
courtyard guarded the helicopter and its
pilot a flying instructor who the men
had taken hostage the helicopter flew to
a nearby gun sit Dustin a area was found
by local police fade is 46 he's been
serving a 25-year sentence for a failed
robbery a mother's second prison escape
Wow
how do you do that little helicopter
yeah by the way I think about the
loyalty he inspires in his men yep cuz
those guys Wow
nearly 3,000 French police have been
drafted into the manhunt anything is
being done to locate this fugitive does
anyone hope he gets away
I do cuz he hasn't killed anyone I don't
think he killed that woman personally I
I kind of hope he'll crack a few eggs
make an omelette fellas he's just saying
I hope he gets a lot of respect the
woman if you didn't kill anyone I kinda
hope you get to live so a month before
yeah there was drones flying you know
look rule Children's into the prison
area to see if there was an area tonight
the chopper so they waited a month after
that plan de system mekin the one
opening they did it back that's an crowd
I bet he is so balls deep in French
girls right nothing funny he's got some
[ __ ] going on where is he is the
question
mmm if he's smart he'll go to a country
that doesn't have an extradition treaty
with France how lawyer has boys he go
get him twice in the 1990s he ran a gang
involved in armed robbery and extortion
French capital who said his lifestyle
was inspired by Howard gangster films
Scarface 14 oh wow he once approached
man who directed heat and said your
might war hero Michael Mann I go man I'm
sure you can see him it's probably
interviews with him wow that's
impressive Matt that's impressive
this is has to be a movie after this
well they're making literally about the
Pink Panthers the smash-and-grab guys
got away with hundreds of million
dollars those with water cycle students
going out they just get on boats they do
all kind they break each other out of
jail and sweats when they're badasses
busy pink Panther's campaign yeah seen
that you seen the footage of those guys
know the way they organized themselves
oh this book the culture code you gotta
read the coast code I said study on
highly successful groups teal team six
Spurs and these guys yes and and this
guy Dan coiled it's an amazing book the
culture card read it Pink Panther what's
that sayin though it's the headline Pink
Panther jewel thief gang arrested after
stealing 280 billion dollars in 380
armed robberies always tried to escape
wearing joke shop wig and fake glasses
all right they got a lot of them they're
from Serbia there's a bunch of them oh
they're amazing and they break each
other out of jail they get arrested they
break each other out of jail with guns
they beat the [ __ ] out of the cards
they're they're rough guys man that
loyalty thing is something as much as it
sucks it's all grew up in war-torn
Serbia and they were close really close
together and they their mafia the only
way the Mafia works is by law yeah
they're so organized who slips
nobody can sink ships yeah they got our
way on boats like in Monaco they'll be
both
literally how they left well sketch in I
think once all the people talk I think
the Leo DiCaprio about doing a movie
about him
who that the the Charles Manson Leonardo
DiCaprio Quentin Tarantino Brad Pitt
movie dropped in November they thought
they were a special forces gang and they
found out they were just the
middle-class kids in Serbia who grew up
in war and had a taste for a risk-taking
well what else kitchen this I don't know
if you knew this but a Thailand Thailand
the soccer team and their coach was
there went missing in a cave the [ __ ]
were they doing in cave I think they
were just playing around and then there
was a monsoon that that went in front of
the cave so they couldn't get out there
I think they were just trying to find
another way out so they were missing for
nine days all these kids and the coach
today they were found everyone's alive
and healthy nice man yeah thank you
twelve boys and a coke ice Belgium
scores and late seconds to beat Japan
[ __ ] crazy okay Anton alright well do
you want to talk about this or Nutkin
Bank McCann hunter images are four black
giraffe trophy kill what you get killed
tonight sparked outrage well it's an old
trap no no the facts not true enough so
don't do that hopefully did you read
this article
yes it's not true no I did read the
article in fact the conservation the
woman who runs the giraffe conservation
thing basically said this is this is not
a rare number one it's not a rare and
yeah number two it is it is actually
good for conservation number three
trophy hunting brings money in and all
that stuff and there was a legal hunt
and everything else so they're not rare
and you get a lot of this one in
particular was never messin who have a
problem with it and stuff and it's just
so [ __ ] silly see the bottom here she
points up the draft was killed too old
to breed had killed 300 holes that were
able to breed causing the horse
population increase so so they're just
making it all up yeah same thing with
rhinos we go rhinos the guy paid 300 the
real thousand dollar i lizard yes but he
paid three hundred ninety five thousand
dollars to shoot a black rhino a radio
lab did a thing on it oh I saw that
really yeah and and
other ones yeah yeah which is what
happens yeah
and it was gonna it was very old and
stuff the only problem I have is when
there like a white rhino or I had no
idea there were black giraffes that's
right I think it older they get black
well he's [ __ ] school two thousand
pounds of meat he's cool again four
thousand pound animal with personal I'm
not in the trophy hunting but it does it
brings money it puts it it makes it
prophase the young ones to write the
population going it is nature doesn't
take care of that though like there's a
reason a boy but remember that this
these areas are already been [ __ ] with
so much other predators on yeah that's
why I'm so so so when you're actually in
the business of conservation to begin
with and managing those parks that make
sense there's all kinds of [ __ ] the
actors that get all [ __ ] bunched up
over this one hunted they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about but
it's so typical of Hollywood to be
outraged you'll find one picture like
with all the problems in the world they
come out all this Jerrod you just saved
it like when I saw there I'm like damn
it so rear-drive why the [ __ ] would you
kill that cool animal but then when you
find out there's a Debra Messing here
the the virtue signal or the one on on
hi the actress test Thompson tally from
Napa or an epoch Kentucky is a
disgusting vile immoral heartless
selfish murderer but but do you eat meat
or with joy and her black heart and a
beaming smile she lies next to the dead
carcass of shut up the drove shut the
[ __ ] I'm Pro hunting so [ __ ] off I'm Pro
hunting too I did it with a bow and
arrow pretty impressive and Ricky hey
race
shut up too well take easy on Ricky
Gervais so she shut up and I'll say she
got that big 100 shot up to nothing with
an arrow it's a giraffe you know like
they're so big dude there's you know
they're like so you're like hey Doc and
they're like this you know sorry bro -
SHhhh
it's so true like like it's it seems I
cook it seal all up it's your largest
target I could crawl up its fat well I
was just gonna hog referrals kill bad
rap recently cuz yet headbutt it yeah
yeah if you're [ __ ] if you're I'd I
would draft don't do they got dragon
ones you just go like this yeah you know
you kill that stupid ref it's like
do you have draft ribs yeah I've eaten
giraffe no you have it sure haven't
Kenny three I wrote me know was a nice
it was delicious
no remember it Oh delicious you know I'm
not going to Kenny I was supposed to but
I have to go to China yeah I know
supposed to see the great migration and
I was gonna Sport shoot just a bunch of
animals and leave them for die
so just for most it you can do it for
the gram so accurate famous actors
commanding just just I was gonna I was
gonna wound them with us yet chin this
is a really cute I wouldn't do it all
through radio is it here no not this one
this one so this video went viral of a
police dog that was trained to do CPR
and it is seriously the cutest thing yes
I'll show you here so they're doing a
demonstration right now the dog's name
is Pancho that's rock oh no see it is
that babies are leaner rut looks like
I'm and then look he does this to hear
if he's still like breathing
that's cute he's just that's just a joke
cute and listening for the heartbeat
that's very French police sport police
yeah ponies love dogs I love dogs
I love animals ite especially oh kill
York lose the giraffe is season and all
black giraffe the right way hey what's
the difference been killing giraffe and
your [ __ ] Corgi nothing yeah probably
right buddy there's more corgis in the
world than giraffes correct
so let me kill you or you know will you
just time i got really old knees killing
all the other breeding thanks okay so I
guess Serena Williams had a new sawed up
person come by and they reported that
she wasn't at where she's supposed to be
in her whereabouts
no but there's controversy because she
said that it was out like a 12-hour
window and then they came earlier than
that or something like that
so she's she found out after this that
she's tested more than any other female
tennis player like five times
I guess there's an issue at the this one
that picks where she didn't go this one
oh I think him at this old one well she
went she didn't she didn't she didn't
competing the Olympics and the rumor was
that they were afraid that she would
pick o greatest great tennis player of
all time so female tennis player all
ties to this fellow didn't mean she's
not juicing but right and if she is
welcome to party or everyone is but also
I I would imagine that a lot of times
players are because the schedule is
insane and you know your body breaks
down also when your that when you're
winning that much I think Ronda Rousey
the most test well there's certain
there's some shady stuff again you saw
does not word it's like the solids
definitely has an agenda there's always
some hidden stuff there yeah it's like
the FDA yeah what else get in that's
pretty much it man let's go kill some
trousers that's it roads come see me
please in Tampa this weekend Friday
Saturday they pay you come on out and
then come see me in Zurich and Gotham
comedy club Thursday June
I mean July yep yep July 12th Thursday
Gotham comedy club and then July 13th
14th I'm gonna be at the funny bone in
Syracuse and then you know what happens
the 19th and 20th Thalia Hall Chicago
yes you and I will be in Chicago
executing black giraffes on stage that's
right buddy I will bring up my opening
act is I'm bringing up fat stupid I'll
be young breeding bulls but we're gonna
paint them black no I just can get one
old stupid black giraffe and slit his
eyes off from the crowd got a guy's
throat nope just his eyes she like he's
such a vulnerable guy with a neck that
long
I know if I'm grabbing it but they're
strong who they're tough they kick you
ever seen them kick okay okay come live
Saturday Oklahoma stand up and watch you
see with me 30 tickets left Cherokee
casinos at tak calm and then I'm in
Spokane Washington next week spoke and
comedy club Spokane's watch Thursday
Friday Saturday and then first two weeks
of August Texas I'm not coming back I
don't care how hot it is first week of
August I'm in Austin cap city those
tickets are almost sold out
second week in Dallas improv Dallas tik
calm we will see you guys on the road we
will see you around
be nice to them black - Raph's this as
if I'm kid we're out